kanye how are you
how are you doing today oh what up baby
how you been
good you with the babies today
enjoy enjoy
that's kanye west stepping out with his
eldest kids north and saint at super
bowl 56 amid some serious divorce drama
with his estranged wife kim kardashian
you got good seats dorothy
the award-winning rapper donned an
all-black look while eight-year-old
north and six-year-old saint sported
football jerseys for the big game
between the los angeles rams and
cincinnati bengals and that glove right
there that was given to yay by la rams
player odell beckham jr who tossed him a
pair before taking the field
[Applause]
[Music]
kanye's appearance comes just hours
after he spent sunday morning firing off
a series of instagram posts many aimed
at kim's current beau pete davidson
alongside a photo of the skim's founder
and the snl star yay writes in part i
don't have beef with kim i love my
family so stop that narrative i'm not
giving up on my family i have faith that
we'll be back together to be in love is
to be crazy about something and i am
crazy about my family happy valentines
just do something for my heart kanye has
been very vocal about kim's new romance
which all started in october after
making her hosting debut on saturday
night live now are you gonna kiss me or
not
i sure am jasmine
turns out the jesus walks rapper wasn't
a fan of that moment you know how you
gonna bring me to snl
and kiss the dude you dating right in
front of me and everybody's like oh
that's that's cool then there's this
lyric on yay's latest single easy god
send me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis's ass
so what does pete think of all of this a
source tells e.t quote pete finds
kanye's lyrics and interviews about him
funny and entertaining he is super chill
about the situation and doesn't take it
too personally but he hates that kim has
to deal with the drama you just gotta
roll with it the source adds the
comedian is helping her through it and
reminds the beauty mogul to not focus on
the drama too much someone who fully
supports kim and pete's relationship her
best friend jonathan cheban the
miami-based influencer told et this
ahead of the big game as kim's one of
kim's closest confidants what do you
think of her and pete together um i
think it's cool yeah you know what she's
having fun i guess you know uh you know
i i've hung out with them a couple of
times and
you know i love her to death so whatever
whatever makes her happy that's her
friend how are you supporting her
through all the kind of the kanye
craziness that's happening i don't even
know anything about that so i love kanye
too man he's a [ __ ] genius excuse me
um but you know listen i just i hope
that i hope everybody
ends up settling